This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Rob.
And I'm Georgina.
What do Vincent Van Gogh and Galileo Galilee have in common, Georgina?
Hmm. Their first name and last names both start with the same letter.
Well, that's true. But another similarity is that their amazing contributions to art and
science were only recognised after their death.
I know another person who's huge contribution to science went unrecognised during her lifetime
rope. But unlike Van Gogh or Galileo, you probably haven't heard of her. She's a subject of this
programme. Henrietta Lacks was a young black American mother who died of cancer in Baltimore
in 1951. Although she never consented to her tissues being used for medical research,
doctors at the time found her cells to have an extraordinary ability to replace themselves
endlessly.
Named healer cells after her initials, Henrietta Lacks' tissue helped make possible all sorts of
medical breakthroughs from the polio vaccine to cancer drugs to HIV and IVF treatments.
Born 100 years ago, in 1920, the great great-granddaughter of slaves,
Henrietta and her cells continue to provide medical discoveries to this day.
Most recently, of course, in the race for a coronavirus vaccine.
But before we go on Georgina, it's time for my quiz question.
I mentioned that Henrietta Lacks was born 100 years ago. But do you know what other medical breakthrough
happened in 1921? Was it A, the discovery of insulin, B, the discovery of penicillin,
or C, the discovery of vitamin E?
I'll say A, the discovery of insulin.
Okay Georgina, we'll find out if that's right later on.
Now, it was Henrietta's biography by science writer Rebecca Sglute that brought her remarkable
story to the world's attention a decade ago.
Here is Rebecca Sglute explaining Henrietta's importance to BBC World Service Program, the forum.
So much of science is based on growing cells and culture, which started with her cells
in vitro fertilization. That started with the ability to grow embryos and culture, which you can
do in part thanks to her cells. So the list just goes on and on. And right now, people are often asking
how are he, how are he, the cells helping with COVID? Scientists work that out very quickly using
her cells. They figured out what the receptor looks like. And they did the same thing with HIV.
So her cells are just this incredible workhorse that is at the base of so much science.
Doctors used Henrietta's cells to figure out or understand how cells reproduce and divide.
Knowledge that was vital in developing in vitro fertilization or IVF, a technique for women
who cannot become pregnant naturally, in which an egg is fertilized outside the body.
Our bodies are made of millions and millions of cells. And to understand how they work,
we need to grow them in a lab. No one had succeeded in doing this until Henrietta's extraordinary
cells which just grew and grew. This resulted not only in fertility treatments, but later in AIDS
and cancer breakthroughs, which is why Rebecca refers to healer cells as a workhorse, meaning
someone who does a lot of work. But perhaps Henrietta's greatest legacy of all was the vaccine
for polio. Here's Professor of Genetics, Sir John Byrne, talking to BBC World Services,
the forum. Henrietta would have particularly liked the announcement this year that polio vaccine
had led to the eradication of polio in Africa. So the centenary of her birth, it seems rather symbolic
that her unwitting contribution to medicine eventually eradicated that scourge of mankind.
John Byrne calls polio as scourge, meaning something causing much pain and suffering.
Henrietta's role in eradicating this terrible disease is all the more remarkable as she was never
asked permission to use her cells for research. And it's taken decades for the Laks family to win
their grandmother the recognition she deserves. That's why John Byrne calls Henrietta's contribution
unwitting. It was made without her knowledge or consent. And with the eyes of the world now focused
on vaccines for the coronavirus, this year is a symbolic time to celebrate her centenary, the 100th
anniversary of an important event. Henrietta Laks, a remarkable woman whose name is finally making
its way into the history books. But something else remarkable happened 100 years ago, didn't it Rob?
Ah yes, you mean my quiz question. I asked you which important medical breakthrough occurred 100
years ago in 1921. I said A, the discovery of insulin. Which was the correct answer? Discovered by
Canadian doctor Frederick Banting, insulin saved the lives of millions of diabetics. And on that healthy
note, let's recap the vocabulary from this program starting with in vitro fertilization or IVF
a medical technique for women who cannot become pregnant naturally. Henrietta's healer cells help
doctors figure out or understand a lot about how cells grow and led to so many medical discoveries
we might call them a workhorse. Something which works extremely hard. A scourge means something
that causes much pain and suffering, like the terrible diseases which Henrietta's unwitting
or unknowing contribution helped eradicate. Making 2021 a year of hope and the perfect time to
celebrate the centenary of her birth, its 100th anniversary. We hope this upbeat program has
been just what the doctor ordered. Remember to join us again soon at 6 Minute English. Bye for now.
Goodbye!